the only morning Matthews Java skate
citizen three kids look at Chris
Hemsworth hitting the waves or as he
calls it some big kegs but he works hard
for that body and his ability to look
like a statue come to life isn't the
same one thing you may not know about
Chris is he loves pizza
and the more pizza he eats the more
shredded he gets and he's gonna hate the
fact that I've just told you that guys
they would look at a dumbbell and he'll
do maybe four or five curls and it's
quadrupled in size how is that even
possible
secrets to how Chris looks like this we
got him thanks to Bobby Holland Hanten
his body double for Thor Snow White and
the Huntsman bad times at the El Royale
and Men in Black Bull mode is the most
difficult out of all of them between six
to eight meals a day chris has a chef on
set they cook for me as well steak in
the morning breakfast it's training
twice a day six days a week so whether
you want to look like Chris or look at
him Thor himself came up with a way to
get you closer to that goal he and Bobby
along with their fellow trainers develop
their own fitness app called Center you
have access to the team I've used over
the years
that team is now your team and as for
how Hemsworth compares to the other
stars Bobby has worked with I've doubled
Christian Bale and Batman I've doubled
Ryan Reynolds in green lanten Channing
Tatum Daniel Craig Jake Gyllenhaal Henry
Cavill Captain America Chris Evans
they're all in fantastic shape get me
wrong but Chris literally was just put
on this earth he's literally a perfect
he's ridiculous
[Music]